i wanted to know what are the
preconditions for liberalism i was
thinking about this
i was thinking was it was you mentioned
which was existential security well no
because you just flipped that you said
actually
liberalism can thrive and then produce
some security
even harsh environments and then i was
wondering well
are there memetic preconditions are
there memes
that need to be dispersed in the society
and
adopted before liberalism can come about
and if so what would those memes be
do you have any ideas other other people
can
do a better job recounting the
history of this but i'll do the best
that i can
for one thing
the cultural evolution of european
society can definitely be seen as a
process of multi-level
selection basically competition between
polities
resulting in larger and larger uh
polities ultimately the scale of
european nations you go back far enough
and you find all these little city
states hundreds and hundreds
of them why don't they exist anymore is
because they had to amalgamate
in order to fight each other and so
that's what resulted in nations the size
of
of european nations that's when when it
comes to nation building and things like
that and we go to other parts of the
world such as africa the
middle east afghanistan which never
actually ever achieved that scale of
of governance and then we expect them to
adopt a european
model that typically doesn't work
because they never achieved that
scale of that scale of governance so
what you ended up with were
very large societies that ultimately
became autocratic
and once again ceased to work for the
common uh good
and then democratic forms of governance
emerged from
their liberalism the enlightenment
values emerged from
there and why
and then that then asserted greater
equality
and uh ultimately resulted in more
powerful
nations if you look for example at the
at the competition between england and
france england is a quarter the size of
france but managed to punch above its
weight in part because
of such things as the industrial
revolution why did that take place in
england and not
france is because actually if you're an
inventor some kind of craftsman or
or watchmaker or something like that in
england and you came up with an
investment you had a way to develop that
investment in a way that you would share
the
benefits of it was it was enough
equality so that the merchant class for
example had had enough so that they
could actually
benefit from this sort of thing then in
a more aristocratic
society and you didn't have to have many
decades of that before you would have
technological advances and so on and so
forth in which you could punch above
your
of your uh your wage
so so and if you look at the actual
origin of these democratic
movements
the masons the freemasons become
a very interesting story here i don't
know if we want to go into it but uh
freemason societies started out
as actually societies of of uh
architects basically the people that
built the great cathedrals and
and so on so it was building and and um
and architects but then it morphed into
a kind of a philosophical society
that could accommodate more sectors of
the
society than normal aristocratic society
so you could become a freemason
and mingle with people
that you couldn't do otherwise out of
your
station and then and then
they were the first ones to form a
actually written constitution
that's a long story i don't sure but
it's uh it's really quite fascinating
that
once again in small groups this became
incubated
and then expanded and led to the
um to the democratic revolutions in
france and
and america and all through all through
europe in some ways was a scaling up
of a form of governance that originated
in
in these little tiny societies